[Music]
hi everyone its Johanna here the month
of ramadhan is approaching and fasting
in the month of Ramadan is an excellent
opportunity to make significant
lifestyle changes for the Muslim it also
teaches you to manage and practice
spirituality which include not eating
excessively I'm not Muslim however I
have practiced fasting for several days
and it can be challenging especially
when you have to fast for more than 17
hours in a day what I'll be sharing with
you in this video is a Ramadan healthy
meal guide good food to nourish your
body portion sizes and food to avoid
which may defeat the purpose of fasting
during the fasting month your metabolism
will slow down due to the long hours
without food and drinks to keep a
balance your diet should have less than
the normal amount of food yet enough to
keep you healthy and active in general
your diet should be simple and does not
differ much from your everyday diet for
those of you who are planning on losing
some weight this month is the perfect
time to make healthier food choices and
to learn about portion control so let's
start with IFTA the food eaten
immediately after sunset to break fast
during this time you want to replenish
your body with fluid and a quick burst
of energy so choose one or two from
these three types of food first fruits
are dried fruits such as date prunes or
raisins fruits contain high amount of
natural sugar for a quick energy boost
go for one small handful of dried fruits
or one piece of fruit second 100%
natural fruit juices or smoothies
without any added sugar you may choose
to sweeten it with a little bit of
natural sweeteners such as honey phryges
contain both natural sugar and fluid to
keep your body hydrated go for one cup
third milk which also contain natural
sugar and water to replenish the body
again go for one cup your meal should be
a small snack just
enough to bring low blood sugar levels
to normal levels then I believe the
Muslim will conduct your Margaret prayer
before having dinner for dinner this
news shouldn't even much from your
regular dinner have a balanced meal
consisting of complex cups protein
vegetables dairy and healthy fats so
let's start with complex carbs complex
cups are food that will help release
energy slowly hence providing your body
with enough energy throughout a day
healthy examples include a basmati rice
chapati barley oats whole grain breads
lentils couscous potatoes and more for a
female aim to have two servings of
convex cups for a meal you can have
three or four servings depending on your
size this one small bowl is two servings
of complex cups please do watch my how
much should I eat to lose weight video
to learn more about portion sizes in
detail next protein because it takes
much longer for protein to break down in
our body having protein will keep you
satisfied for much longer and to keep
cravings under control if you intend to
do a short workout session before dinner
then having protein in your meal will
also help with muscle recovery healthy
examples include big or grilled chicken
such as tangerine land beef eggs
chickpeas any type of beans fish seafood
tofu tempeh and more one serving of
protein is one ounce for female if you
have two or three servings for meal add
one or two additional servings third
group vegetables vegetables are
extremely low in calories high in fiber
hence they will keep you satisfied and
it is hard to over eat them if you
intend to watch your weight during this
fasting month then pack your plate fill
with vegetables healthy examples include
green leafy vegetables onions olives
cucumbers carrots cauliflower and more
one serving of vegetable is about 80
gram aim to have at least two to three
servings of vegetable on your dinner
plate or have as much of vegetables as
you want next day
nowadays there are a lot of
controversial in regards to the pros and
cons of dairy products some of you might
not consume dairy as part of your meal
or you may be lactose intolerance
whatever your stand is on dairy products
consume them in moderation so if you
intend to add them as part of your meal
go for one serving healthy examples
include one glass of milk or buttermilk
one small part of yogurt or cottage
cheese or one slice of cheese this can
be consumed separately or it may be
added as part of your cooking and the
final group is healthy fats examples of
healthy fat include 1 TSP or 1 tbsp of
olive oil a small handful of nuts or
seeds fish such as salmon which is high
in omega-3 fatty acids and avocado
healthy fat are usually added as part of
your cooking for instance lightly
stir-fried with 1 teaspoon of olive oil
instead of using butter or ghee make
hummus or sprinkle salad with a little
bit of olive oil nuts or seeds healthy
fats is good for you however they are
still fat and they are very high in
calories so consume them in small amount
now that you know what should be on your
dinner plate your preparation method is
key to even make a meal healthy or
unhealthy so choose to prep your meal by
grilling boiling steaming or baking
instead of deep-frying which will
destroy most of the nutrients here's an
example of what a healthy dinner can be
complex cups one small bowl of rice
protein 3 ounces of chicken breast
steamed with herbs and spices vegetable
dairy and healthy fats 3 servings of mal
vegetable curry in which I've used 1 TSP
of olive oil and 1 cup of yogurt
remember that your dinner should remain
a dinner not the feast after dinner a
lot of time for your body to digest and
register the feeling of fullness
remember that it takes at least 20
minutes for your body and mind to know
that you are full so do not rush and
finish your dinner in 15 minutes instead
pace yourself out and take your time to
really enjoy the food that you have been
blessed
thirty minutes after dinner or before
bedtime consume one to two servings of
fruits to facilitate digestion and to
prevent any in digestion issues you may
choose to have a fruit on its own or
make a yoga pathway with fruits nuts or
seeds if you still feel slightly hungry
late at night choose small healthy
snacks to keep hunger at bay without
feeling too overly full please watch my
plan healthy late-night snacks or under
100 calories snack ideas for recipes as
for suho your pre-dawn meal and to
consume a wholesome moderate meal high
in fiber complex carbs and protein which
are filling and will provide you with
enough energy for many hours here are my
10 slow digesting recipes which are lied
but will provide you with enough energy
and keep you healthy peanut butter toast
with banana slices egg on toast egg
muffins fruit smoothies green smoothies
yogurt parfait chicken summer soup
noodles chunky veggie barley soup peanut
butter oatmeal and overnight oats these
are all very quick and simple recipes
which can be prepped under 15 minutes or
less some of them can even be made the
day before all these recipes are
available under my Ramadan playlist
which you can click here the serving
size should be approximately half of
your dinner size so for instance you can
have one solid meal such as peanut
butter toast with banana slices and one
liquid meal such as green smoothie this
combination will provide you with enough
energy for many hours avoid overeating
or consuming heavy news for soup or as
it can make you feel lethargic and
sluggish right from the start of the day
and we do not want that just like your
regular healthy daily meals the food you
want to avoid include fast food and
heavily processed food such as burger
chips deep-fried samosas or fried
chicken second food high in refined
carbs such as white bread or white flour
which mainly if you're feeling hungry
again very quickly but too much fancy
and high
sugar food such as oily curries anything
deep-fried cakes biscuits pastries
chocolates traditional sweets and more
you might want to avoid spicy food as it
can cause indigestion bloating and
discomfort to the stomach and avoid all
reduce on your caffeine intake such as
coffee tea or coke because they contain
a diuretic properties which can
stimulate quicker water loss through
urination if you're someone who drinks
capping on a regular basis reducing
caffeine drastically can cause headache
irritability and mood swings so reduce
your caffeine gradually three to five
days before Ramadan yes there may be
occasions where you create for your
favorite naughty food or days where you
are invited to face with your families
and friends there is nothing wrong with
treating yourself as long as you
practice mindful eating fasting in the
month of Ramadan is an excellent
opportunity to make significant
lifestyle changes such as understanding
your relationship with food listening to
your body when you eat learning
self-control and most importantly to
appreciate the food you have been
blessed with to conclude aim to drink
lots of water between iftar and silver
to avoid dehydration aim to eat real
food food in its purest form eat food
that will keep your body hydrated eat
lots of vegetables and fruits and
remember that your bills should not
differ much from your regular healthy
meals and Ramadan should not be an
excuse for you to stop exercising in
fact you should continue with your
regular exercises and keep them between
30 to 45 minutes with slightly lower
intensity the best time to workout is
after your evening prayer before dinner
or before suborn select this month of
Ramadan with the start to a healthier
you
by creating positive eating habits with
a heightened level of consciousness and
spirituality lots of love and happy
Ramadan for new Fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you
[Music]
[Music]